un 44e salon d'automne andresy pour
faire connaître l'art de la peinture et
de la poésie
l'amicale des beaux-arts à sélectionner
les artistes présents en amont un
événement devenu incontournable selon le
président de l'association
le salon d'andrésy devient un salon qui
est maintenant réputé donc
automatiquement d'alcon contacter ses
peintres parce que de bouche à oreille
des artistes il en parle
chaque saint très beau salon et de
qualité donc ils viennent dès qu'on les
contacts ils sont contents de venir
exposer vendredi j 22 artistes ont
exposé leurs oeuvres à l'espace julien
green l'événement permettait de
rencontrer le public et d'avoir un
retour sur leur travail
lloyd et des gens avertis m'intéresse de
savoir comment ils ressentent
comment ils perçoivent les peintures les
tableaux les sujets aussi donc ça
m'intéresse de savoir
et puis d'être reconnue aussi ça fait
plaisir quand on a des quand on apporte
de l'émotion de la satisfaction aux
visiteurs
sur place acrylique peinture à l'huile
collages ou encore sculpture au total
120 oeuvres étaient à découvrir chaque
artiste dispose et 2,5 grillé pour
exprimer son univers ils ont un bel
espace où les oeuvres sont sont bien
représentés normalement dans les salons
il ya une ou deux heures alors que là on
laisse vraiment l'espace pour exprimer
un travail
l'exposition devait être visible
jusqu'au 25 octobre en raison d'un
arrêté préfectoral faisant suite aux
nouvelles mesures sanitaires
l'événement a été écourté